hey guys I was like oh get so seen and
this is my sister Jenna hello and we are
getting prepared for Valentine's Day
which is February 14th in case you
didn't know I think it's a silly holiday
but what I do love is celebrating by
making baked goods I love doing
blindfolded challenges with Jenna and we
did a blindfold gift exchange during
Christmas and these are the only
blindfolds that I could find this is a
question that I have for you guys wait
let me ask Nick first Nick what do you
call these dream dream big
they don't say that's all conversation
hearts we came from the same family but
I don't know where your twisted little
brain called them conversation
conversation works they've always been
called conversation Oh freaking on the
bag is this a different brand other than
the sweetheart through there like we
have to call it something else this is
the authentic uh-huh we know it's not
funny taste I'll tell you all color
pigment taste
y'all are gonna taste the same you're
ruining everything they're sweethearts I
am 28 years old and in my lifetime I've
never once been like all I love when a
boy get a conversation heart
no one's ever give me a Valentine I'm
sure that's why that's the generic
ripoff version of the sweethearts they
can't call them sweetheart that's a
lawsuit no wait we're gonna figure this
out we're proud to be your favorite
candy maker for over a hundred years
okay how many years of Yavin making
candy Alexa when we're sweethearts
Candy's invented
18:47
Congress yeah everybody says that they
won't have a conversation I'm like
you're like I'll break it up would you
please admit to the camera either one
will do I'm wrong what the hell your
conversation are eat it wrong so that's
gonna be on one of my hearts the other
one's gonna be called butt slap and the
other one's gonna be called Jenna's
always right oh geez okay well I guess
we're gonna have to write that
blindfolded so what we're gonna do is
when we decorating and blindfolding and
writing a conversation to each okay ah I
am sick of your mouth I'm Jenna I'm
always right everything I'm saying is
right I'll find that on that
conversation part and shove in your
mouth could we get a zoom in on what
this is impossible
so Jenna and I are going to decorate
these cakes blindfolded and because the
conversation hearts have words on them
conversations we're going to write a
conversation to each other that's what
you do when you talk to someone it's a
conversation and you're like oh someone
wrote me a conversation letter it's like
it's a love letter oh cool it's not a
sweetheart letter well it's better than
a conversation like I have a
conversation with Matty and like or like
a tree I've got some things to decorate
I think basically we're gonna decorate
with this icing oops and then we have
this you've got a little black and a red
all right blindfold on all right let's
go morning I'm done so I need to find my
oh it's so crazy I can't find anything
already oh that's the cake okay hey Roy
yes the cake yes the cake so so I feel
the cakes you sure that's the cake yeah
it's a cake so I think the icing is let
me feel around for it
Oh without a conversation heart box -
okay see here it go a little bit to the
left my left or your left wait
here okay I've managed to find you five
there you go right here I'll put it in
front of you here is this the way you
have it oh yes you says so are we both
wait don't move stop how'd you know I
moved it as I felt it like this was this
was this was here wait where are you at
watch those paws lady okay hold on let's
move this closer do you feel it oh I'm
sorry I didn't see you there okay so
this is think I'm icing I'm pretty I
gotta get more is where's the bowl wait
that's your arm you're are you icing my
body I mean I'm going for the bolas I
don't know what the problem is oh I
can't imagine this looks good because I
I can't see what I'm doing I wonder if
anything's coming up and it's like
everything's real sticky yeah yeah it's
definitely yep definitely Oh God glitter
gel sucks how do you know it's glitter
because I know I what I picked up how do
you know oh shoot I'm pretty sure it is
I can't feel where the icing is how oh
here I can help you I know where one is
oh oh here it is here you go
what you can't see where are you wait
look out lower your [__] here you're
nowhere near me is the cap on yes
feels like the cat wind yeah it is on
the aggressive you t but wow if I just
stand here I start falling backwards oh
oh one second I'm trying to I'm trying
to right what are you doing what are you
doing wait where's your cake that's
another cake that's another that's bonus
cake I'm assuming I can't see okay well
I'm gonna just put some more I'm gonna
just put uh somebody in because I
thought they'll be able to get into
better grasp of it am i right in this
about you or just about in the
conversation heart have a conversation
conversation heart let's have a
conversation
are you still here I just went home
don't push me
oh no I need a little bit more icing oh
hey what is it room my way I'm gonna say
I'm did you pinch me huh try an icing
I'm gonna say love L o V so I'm gonna do
like a nice heart outline yeah it's
really hard to tell things coming out I
can't see what I'm doing I know I keep
like I feel like it's I'm trying to do
like it felt like a hurt hour
oh no I'm gonna put this down so far
[Music]
okay I think I'm done hold on I'm not
done I'm I know I'm not sure what I'm
doing I can't see anything so you did -
I only got sad you want this just slow
ready one two three
Oh yours looks like trash what did you
write I'm ugly be perfect yes you guys
like a dumpster was that Dexter inspired
did you have what your blindfold on you
yeah in the mascara supposed to be a
heart that is nothing like what I
thought I was doing this one were
supposed to say but slab I'm sleeping
[Laughter]
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh I'm so sorry I promise I'm not this
mean I'm
maybe I'm actually crying what kind of a
conference no friendly having a convo it
hurts so bad
what happens when you keep Jenna out
past our bedtime I'm starting to feel a
little bit bad
he bought me dinner tonight and this is
what I did to her Wow conversation got
to do got to do with it Justine I'm
sorry I didn't have my one well yeah I
figured you creaking groped perfect
calligraphy on your conversation heart
and I look like this it's just the prank
bro what's up play when a man loves a
woman
[Music]
you